food and bradley cooper come on that's
awesome
[Music]
burn the burnt stars bradley cooper
bradley cooper plays who used to be a
rock star chef this dude had everything
he was the guide to be then he ruined
his life he lost it all he fell from
grace and now a couple years later he
wants Redemption he wants to be the best
chef on earth so it becomes the head
chef of this one kitchen you get sienna
miller as a sous chef they're gonna make
it happen or they're gonna make it
cliched romance happen in the movie that
you knew was coming anyway I was
seriously we didn't see that coming but
I'll tell you what I liked about the
movie first of all I like the characters
in this movie and I like the actors
portraying them everyone did a great job
in this movie Bradley Cooper Sienna
Miller Daniel Bruhl and a lot of names
I'm not mentioning because I'm
completely forgetting them everyone did
a great job
Bradley Cooper was really good as this
super damaged chef you can't hold down a
relationship he pisses everyone off
around him he wants to be the best at
his craft I get that I like that I liked
the D even though he was kind of a dick
I didn't like the character in the mood
what kind of irritated me is the movie
around those characters really if you
look at it it's a pretty by-the-numbers
movie about a guy who was awesome and
then he fell from grace and he wants to
be awesome again when he has a really
attractive single mom is a sous chef how
do you think that's gonna go down yeah
it does just like that just as
unbelievable is that - why do when dudes
and chicks work together in a movie why
do they have to form a romance I mean
really a movie that had a dude and a
chick work really close together and
work well together and they didn't have
a romance was Pacific Rim that's a movie
I love but I recognize it shouldn't have
been the movie that broke that ground
but really this movie takes place in a
kitchen
it has chefs so in that they should
really make you love food as much as
they do and that's what was missing from
this movie this movie should have had
scenes where Bradley Cooper really
breaks down what goes with what why this
works with this he take Breaking Bad
season 1 Breaking Bad season 1 had many
scenes quite a few scenes where Walter
White broke down chemistry and science
that's a subject a lot of people sleep
through in high school but he explained
it in a way that made it interesting and
fascinating it's like oh yeah this has a
chemical reaction with this and this
works with this and that's why you need
to do this with this it was not only
interesting it established that he is no
joke this guy is every bit as
part about this subject as you are led
to think he is I should have been
Bradley Cooper Bradley Cooper should
have been the culinary Walter White
scenes where someone screws something up
and he's just like no you can't use that
with that no the salts gonna dry that
out you need to do this sauce at OC
tasted boom that's why you do that that
would have fascinated me it would have
engaged the audience more it would have
Illustrated why this guy is every bit as
brilliant as the movies telling you he
is and in the end the movie never really
illustrates that I'm sure these scenes
do happen in these montage jump cuts
yeah I'm saying jump cuts but they're
jump cut montages that happen where
someone's cooking sup it's like and then
just cooker cooker cooker cook montage
montage and they tasted the games I
don't like what happened why was it
better why was it [ __ ] the first time
was it dry was it seared was the sauce
wrong what made it better in the end
were led to believe that Bradley Cooper
is this brilliant chef because he
screams gets pissed and throws plays
against the walls I think we're just
supposed to nod and go Chef Ramsay does
that now we know all the brilliant chefs
do that there are a zillion movies about
someone who is the best in their craft
who wants the world to know it too what
makes these movies different are the
characters and the jobs they have the
craft they have that they are the best
at if you don't properly illustrate why
this craft is interesting or why they're
the best at it ultimately you have
someone who is the best at job exit jobs
interchangeable and he could have just
had any career whatsoever Bert had the
potential to be one of the best movies
of the year I think and in the end it
was less than good enough for me to say
you need to go watch this movie in that
the squandered potential gets me kind of
pissed
Bradley Cooper was great in the movie
everyone in the movie was great in the
movie the movies surrounding these
characters was a pretty by-the-numbers
movie that didn't really illustrate why
the culinary world should be as
interesting as the movie wants you to
think it is so I will say burnt sadly
probably be a good time if you're drunk
ya know it's a party hey didn't tell him
about the Michelin Man yeah I guess the
whole thing in this movie is if there
are these Michelin men and they will go
into a restaurant two at a time and
they'll order water and a half a bottle
of wine and put a fork on the ground see
if anyone notices if we want the
greatest service ever do that in a
restaurant they'll think you're there to
judge them boom be prepared for the best
service ever
right so Burt have you seen it what did
you think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]